okay we've got a couple voicemails to
play for you the voicemail number is two
one nine two david p you can call in any
time of day we have first a voicemail
they're both the theme is they're both
related to me having been away on
vacation last week the first one is from
a regular and very conspiratorial and
and sort of anti-semitic conspiracy
caller okay and he had an idea about ben
Dixon and why Ben was selected to fill
in for me take a listen to this yeah
David that was clever putting a black
person as a show host real clever but
that doesn't distinguish your purpose it
doesn't it doesn't cover the purpose of
trying to give the impression that
you're liberal you are Zionists you're a
racist
you're about apartheid and that's why
you won't go after that topic you stay
away from that topic and I've been
watching you for a while you do
everything other than that you stay away
from that topic and I understand why you
know that the Israeli government and its
lackeys are watching and like I keep
telling you whenever you need some money
all you got to do is keep doing what
you're doing and the Islamic corporation
that you call Israel will make sure you
get as much money as you need remember
they're using taxpayers money from all
over the world so you can get all the
money you want yeah yeah when is the
money going to come in
you would think now that we're in a in a
financial hardship because of the
YouTube ad boycott uh you'd think the
money would be pouring in but of course
it's not yes Ben Dixon was hand-picked
because he's black to distract from my
position on the israeli-palestinian
conflict okay and then the eggman also
checking in he's glad we're back hi Dave
welcome back how come when you say if
the New York Times you don't say
failing New York Times glad you're back
from other shallow yeah
I'm still referring to the New York
Times is just the New York Times I've
not adopted Don
Trump's phraseology of the failing New
York Times maybe someday if it actually
starts failing great bonus show today
driverless cars are learning from
traffic in the video game Grand Theft
Auto google says it's on track to
definitively prove that it has a quantum
computer within a few months and I have
got stories from here in Las Vegas for
you david pakman.com slash membership to
sign up and get instant access to the
bonus show patreon.com slash david
pakman show to contribute to our patreon
fundraiser we will speak to you on the
bonus show next